chaque semaine c'est le même rituel
la fourrière de poissy amène à la spa de
plaisir les animaux errants retrouvé ce
jeudi fin mais c'est une labrador est
une chatte qui rejoignent son chien près
de 200 chats et quelques rougeurs déjà
abandonnés ici
après les papiers administratifs les
agents de la spa prennent en charge les
animaux
la mine est d'un an baptisé tania par
l'équipe est placé à la chatterie
pendant ce temps la chienne molly
passent une visite médicale chez le
vétérinaire du refuge
lecture de la puce électronique et
contrôle de routine ou vérifie son état
de santé général donc on examine la
bouche les yeux les oreilles
une telle passion nominale on vérifie
les articulations versets de l'arthrose
on vérifie la peau pour finir un vaccin
alors on veut me sentais après la case
médical direction le chenil molly passe
alors devant les box de ses copains de
galère mais la labrador n'attendra
finalement que quatre jours avant d'être
adopté par un couple avec enfant molia
chanceuse car le délai moyen de séjour
en refuge et de 42 jours et en ce moment
c'est plutôt une période creuse pour les
adoptions
c'est très calme au mois de juin donc
les départs en vacances juillet ça
reprend un petit peu et au mois d'août
des adoptions reprennent et après on a
des mois qu'ils sont plus intéressants
que d'autres
la petite tania aussi mignonne soit elle
attend toujours ses nouveaux maîtres
la spa organise ce week-end des portes
ouvertes
l'occasion peut être de faire une bonne
action